it's great to have back on the program
today Joe Walsh former U.S
representative from Illinois former
presidential candidate host of the
podcast white flag with Joe Walsh always
great to have you on I appreciate it
David always good to be with you I'm a
huge fan thank you thank you um so okay
let's let's just jump right into the the
some of the meat here 2022 for
historical reasons should have been
great for Republicans Red Wave predicted
by some red wave that ended with
Democrats gaining a seat although now
they kind of lost it because of Kirsten
Cinema but it seems she'll still I guess
caucus with Democrats it's still sort of
shaking out
Ronald McDaniel was recently asked on
Fox News how much of what happened was
because of Donald Trump and she said she
doesn't really want to talk about that
to what degree do you think what
happened is because of Donald Trump
I I think pretty much the whole thing
was because of Donald Trump
um Americans rejected all these crazy
these bat you know what crazy election
denying candidates where did all these
election denying crazy anti-democracy
candidates come from Trump
Trump pushed them they came from his
stable they are him uh and and I give
David I give Biden a lot of credit
because he stuck to this defending
democracy thing uh when a lot of smart
Democratic advisors said come on
President Biden move off of that focus
on inflation and gas but he stuck with
it I think of a lot a lot of Americans
generally said we do want to defend
democracy they're assuming that that's
true and again when you look at split
tickets like when you look at Georgia
for example and you see Brian Kemp
easily won and then Herschel Walker lost
I mean not by much but he did lose but
the gap between Walker and Kemp was
significant it does suggest that
Republican voters were Discerning in
terms of which Republicans they they
were willing to vote for once we look at
that
we have a new poll that finds almost
two-thirds of Republicans even if they
like Trump policy they don't want him to
be the nominee in 2024 there are
increasingly analyzes that say Trump
won't even make it to the first
primaries is what do you think
I I'd say I'd say two things David he's
the king of this party he right now
Remains The Cult leader my former party
is a cult so do not write him off
at all uh but what I will say is this
I'm in a weird spot right because I come
from the mega cult I still engage with
the mega cult every day and I will say
two things about
republican-based voters that I talk to
every day
they all want trumpism
they all want that uh and we all know
what that is and increasingly they're
concerned and worried that maybe Trump
is no longer the voice of that not
here's the important Point David that
you know not because they think there's
anything wrong with Trump they just
don't think he can win
uh so will this be permanent I don't
know and and I don't the other thing I'd
say David is who's going to slay the
king who's going to slay him well I mean
it's it is interesting that DeSantis
without having even announced in some
polls is easily beating a former
president of the United States that it's
a signal that maybe DeSantis can do it
but you know when I think about imagine
de Santa says I'm running and a national
campaign starts I you know I don't know
I mean Ken DeSantis actually handle that
I'm not sure I know DeSantis uh I know
him pretty well uh in in the pre-trump
days
um look he's got Zero Charisma he's not
good on his feet yeah uh he's very
thin-skinned and most Republicans around
the country really don't know who he is
he is a marker right now he's a default
spot for all these Trump voters who want
trumpism and they don't know where else
to go I tend to believe that once he's
under a national Spotlight I don't think
he'll do well yeah and and I've read a
number of pieces that say brilliant guy
uh much more competent than Trump but
sort of like constitutionally he may not
really have what it takes to actually
face the the national campaign with the
nicknames and the but but at the same
time it is a different Trump I mean if
you just look at Trump's something I
don't know what's going on with Trump
but when you look at video from six
years ago from from 2015 2016 his
facility with language and the insults
and the quips and whatever he does seem
diminished at this point to some degree
would you agree
uh I don't know but I do what I do know
David is uh where's he been I I get that
he had to announce a month ago because
if he didn't announce he'd look like you
know a loser so he had to come out yeah
thinking that the midterms would be a
big victory for him
but I got to tell you something David
every single day I hear Republican
voters tell me every day Hey Joe shut up
Twitter did steal the 2020 election I
told you it was rigged now this is a
huge issue an animating issue for
Republican voters it's a it's a layup
for Trump
and I don't know why Donald Trump has
not been more active I don't know why
he's not on Twitter I don't know why
he's not holding a rally somewhere right
now screaming that Twitter stole the
2020 election yeah it's it's strange a
report I don't remember if it was Vanity
Fair or which one that Trump has barely
left his house since making the
announcement he did an interview with
oan yesterday where he's mentioning I
guess some rallies that maybe are
planned but it's it's I don't know how
much momentum is going to be behind
those at this point is there still a
standard Bearer right now in the
Republican party that is the more kind
of prototypical conservative
constitutionalist small government
Republican like is it is it like Mitt
Romney maybe is there anyone left right
now no huh David there's no standard
Bearer for that wing of the party
because I don't believe that wing of the
party is a real Wing anymore the
standard part of the standard her Bear
for the party is still Trump until
somebody knocks him down and here's
here's
about all the time David I left the
party two and a half years ago one of
Trump's most outspoken critics I'm still
a crazy tea party conservative if I ran
in a Republican primary next year
I wouldn't have a shot because I oppose
Trump Liz Cheney could never win in this
party Adam kinzinger could never win so
if not Trump the party is either you
love Donald Trump or you'll be just like
him better than Trump I don't see room
for any other Republican for a while it
does seem though that in the right
District you would absolutely have a
shot doesn't it I mean if in a less
trumpy District I don't know any
Republican primary in a Republican
primary well I mean listen I guess it
depends to what degree the Trump Maga
Association continues to be to diminish
in in importance I guess I guess we
don't know
I I would David Peck I would probably
have better luck running as a very
conservative Democrat maybe so
maybe so maybe so what do you expect now
in the in these next two years because
of course Democrats will have the
majority in the Senate depending on what
happens with Kirsten Cinema it'll be 50
50 or it'll be 51.49 but either way it
is it's a majority to get things done
that require a simple majority probably
can't get much done that requires 60
votes over in the House Republicans
taking control clearly an interest in
investigating Hunter Biden maybe even
Hillary's emails maybe Whitewater we
don't know how far back they're going to
go what exactly is going to happen
legislatively if anything at all nothing
right now that that for certain David we
know that nothing legislatively is going
to happen uh my former colleagues in the
house have made it clear and they're not
going to Veer off of this that they're
going to investigate every Democrat that
they can investigate and they may try to
impeach a few Democrats Kevin McCarthy I
still believe will be speaker but David
he's sold every inch of his body and I
know a lot of people say this I said
this a long time ago Marjorie Taylor
green will will be the speaker in
reality really you'll be squeezing
McCarthy so hard for two years it it's
it's going to be her and the other thing
we know these next two years are going
to be like is it's going to be Trump
craziness I think he's going to be
indicted I think he may be indicted a
couple times and then what do Republican
party voters do do they rally around him
do they say that's it I don't know
when it comes to the hunter Biden stuff
I haven't heard you weigh in on it you
know my view has been I don't really
care about Hunter Biden in the sense
that he has nothing to do with the
administration if he did commit some
crime and you can prove it
investigate indict what what I just
don't care I've no it's like I wasn't
out there defending Anthony Weiner and I
just I don't really care it's the
problem I have is it's being used to
attack Joe Biden in a way that seems
disconnected from the facts that we have
right now what is your sense of the of
the entire Hunter Biden situation it's
it's uh David you nailed it it's purely
political I mean I've had some
Republicans tell me privately
that they have to go after Hunter Biden
because the base is demanding it look
let's let's be real I think you and I
are consistent on this it pisses me off
to no end when people use their service
or their family servicing government to
enrich themselves Jared Kushner did that
Hunter Biden did that with his dad for
years that's not his dad that's him the
justice department will decide what they
want to do with him but this is just
David this is red meat red meat for the
base and they have to throw some of this
stuff at them for these two years do you
think they will go as far in the house
as to actually try to impeach Joe Biden
no
uh I I I don't I there are some in the
caucus who want to
but I think generally as McCarthy is
trying to become speaker he's cutting
deals with everybody
I believe that's probably one promise he
couldn't make um as you mentioned uh
even though you've left the Republican
party and your anti-trump you were one
of the prominent voices in the Tea Party
Movement back in you know 2010-ish and
at the time quite quite a strong
opponent of pres then President Barack
Obama's in retrospect Obama wasn't
really too bad right even even by your
standards
David when I look back sometimes I want
to slap myself upside the head because
you're right Obama Obama wasn't a crazy
leftist
uh in being in Congress then and that
the talking points were always we had to
call them a socialist and all of the
rest yeah and I engaged in too much of
that but oh my God no no not at all and
I've I've obviously over the years
gained much respect for Barack Obama
even if I still genuinely disagree with
him on most policy issues uh to talk
about a policy issue because last time
we did this and it was interesting on
taxes right so top federal tax rate
right now is 37 and there's the idea of
maybe it would go a little higher if Joe
Biden got his way but we're talking
about a couple points and then some say
well we should have a higher bracket
that starts higher with an even higher
tax rate what do you think about the
level of federal taxation in the U.S
right now like what would if it was just
up to you how would you organize tax
brackets If I Were King of the world
David yeah I I'd get rid of our
complicated tax code uh I my my innate
fault is always to let every American
keep more the money they make I'd
Advocate and push some sort of flat tax
one single rate for everybody I'd get
low income people off of it but
everybody else would pay the straight 25
26 percent of what you make and be done
with all these complications and all
these wealthy people who can hire all
these accountants and lawyers to end up
paying nothing well so that's the
critical question when people bring up a
flat tax which is okay
you deal with Folks at the lower end by
saying it's actually zero up until a
certain point but then the first
question becomes is there a single
dollar number at which it goes from 0 to
26 because then that's the first thing
people would game right to try to stay
right below that because 0 to 26 is a
big difference so so one one way around
that is to just incrementally raise it
to a certain point so it's no longer
flat is it then it's no longer flat but
it tops off at a rate but I I hear that
concern and that's a concern I've always
had I'm not I'm less concerned about
that than uh the multitude of rates that
create the multitude of complication
that people like you and I just can't
take advantage of so then the critical
part really is at the top because
effective
these billionaires aren't paying 26
right now so right now if you do a flat
tax that phases in at the bottom from
zero that's so it's already kind of
progressive then
what do you do at the top to prevent
getting deductions and carry a lot you
know interest carry forwards and all
these things how do you really make a
billionaire pay 26 effective because for
most of them that's an increase in what
they pay well so so and again we're
talking Pie in the Sky dreams of course
of course just remember I'm I'm king of
the world yes if I put that number in
there that flat rate of 26 27 28 yep I
would get rid of every deduction every
exemption everything on the books I
remove all of it
in my dream world
what about wages versus capital gains
that's another way right which is well
sure it's 26 flat but I can pay much
less depending on what it is by not
taking a salary as many of these guys
don't what do you do about that
I've always
we
great stuff David damn it and I miss
this stuff do this I'd get rid of the
capital gains tax don't just make it
earning same as income
yeah yeah don't don't throw anything at
me I'd probably I'd probably just just
count it as straight income and I'd get
rid of the capital I'd get rid of every
exception and I would count everything
as income what's crazy about this plan
is it's not very right wing really I
mean like as we talk through it you're
basically saying tax capital gains is
income which increases the amount rich
people pay take away the loopholes and
the deductions which if you can get the
very rich to pay an effective rate of 26
they're actually paying more and just
make it Progressive from zero up to that
26 at the bottom it's it's probably
something a lot of left Wingers would
get behind I mean it doesn't sound bad
to me would it in your mind David would
it end up bringing in more Revenue than
what we're bringing in now I don't know
but it sounds like it might it might
yeah it actually that's the weird funny
thing is it actually might yeah policy
folks we've been speaking but by the way
David neither medical party is
incentivized right to go down that road
absolutely absolutely former Republican
Congressman Joe Walsh you can hear him
on white flag with Joe Walsh always
great having you on
keep doing your thing David thank you
man